is where I get my strength from whenever
I come home this is the beginning of my
world you know when something bad
happens people write it off the son fat
this was very bad I was 15 years old and
I found my mother then I had nowhere to
go but you know what the good thing was
I had a family a different way it's the
people you're gonna meet the people
you're gonna see today was what time I
could always call this guy and he would
just show up and he'd bring food $30 1/2
a number you know I saw that he just
knew I mean nothing was ever I mean no
just last year I got stuck in the
[ __ ] metalheads at the Newark and I
called him at 1:00 in the morning he
came and got me this is this has been 30
years or just I mean I can't give him I
can't give him the gift he gave me he
gave me a gift and again he's none of
the guys that 35 years we still talk
once a week we giggle we [ __ ] I can't
get ahold of my call the front that's
for his mother I mean this is the world
to me I mean this is my [ __ ] world
all these guys that you seen it is
interview today this is my world
and I just want you guys to me as my man
lubes championship this is the call my
balls an old house from behind when I
was a kid this part of the house wasn't
there
that was what we play there we had a
basketball court we had weights there
and carmine had all his cars in there
and stuff everybody is only as good as
his heart tells me whether you're
crooked good bad or indifferent it's
here you got caught you got everything
my children had a lot even listed giggle
I said I took a kid from Cuba I said and
he turned around and just became another
son of mine I said so don't tell me
about kids would hot and I said we used
to call him spit and everybody who says
they don't say that and I said why don't
you know what that
means I've done of the union walls a
spit means
Spanish people in command that's what it
means
so don't use it the wrong way oh I don't
know I don't because I got one with me
he's part of my family
you